I actually had the moon on our set
replaced with the Death Star check it
out and I think it looks pretty cool we
put this up two hours ago and tried it
for the first time at rehearsal and I
was told that one of our staff members
had an issue with it and of course it's
our show's resident Star Wars expert
Jordan shlonsky let's bring him out here
and find out what the problem
okay
thank you
yeah soaking it in he's just soaking it
in what a stylish mortician Jordan
Jordan what do you think of our Death
Star I thought was pretty accurate but
you have a problem is that right look I
appreciate the effort but in terms of
accuracy there was some significant
issues okay what do you mean what is
wrong with it well the first glaring
error is the size of this Death Star
it's depicted here as being far too
large astronomically speaking you see
Earth's moon is just under three
thousand four hundred and seventy five
kilometers in diameter
in fact three thousand four hundred and
seventy four point five seven four
kilometres to be precise however the
original Death Star was only two hundred
and sixteen kilometers in diameter that
means for it to appear as large as it
does in the night sky it needs to be
much much closer to the earth however
the Empire would never maneuver the
deaths are so close to a potential
target as it would essentially be
placing the crown jewel of its own fleet
within the blast radius of an exploding
planet and the deaths are fires its
primary weapon the super laser this
incredibly tight orbit effectively
removes the option
[Applause]
let me get this straight this audience
was incredibly happy to see him show up
but even happier when he was what he was
killed he was a boy he's here Oh bigger
yay he's dead
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please